hey what's up welcome back to my channel
my name is samuel leeds i'm a property
investor
and yesterday i offered
to give away one of my houses
for free and today i just thought i
would
talk about what happened also answer
people's questions usually some days i
do a q a
style video so hey if you've got
questions for me about
anything about what happened yesterday
about property about me whatever it is
ask away in the comment box and i'll
always try and respond to your questions
so i'll be this one next week
however i've had literally thousands and
thousands of people
viewing yesterday's video it was a
social experiment
hundreds of people have been commenting
and asking questions so i thought i'd
just address some of the questions
so before i go ahead and do that would
you do me a massive favor hit the like
button i spend so much time
making youtube videos offering free
houses to people like crazy stuff
um all i ask is that you subscribe to
the channel and hit the like button in
return that would be amazing
so what happened yesterday so what
happened was quite literally
i was in london i walked around
hyde park with the contract
to a house that i own there's no
mortgage on the house
it's only encumbered it's worth about 60
000 pounds and there's tenants in there
paying 450 pounds a month
and i walked around with a contract
stopping people in the park saying hey
would you like to sign
up for this house you can have it
not one person
took the contract and signed it
no one most people ignored me
other people thought i was joking other
people
looked through the contract and thought
it must be a scam maybe there was a
clause in there somewhere
i gave people as much time as they
wanted to read over the contract
i even said you want to call your
solicitor and they said
i can't be
bothered it's crazy
i mean one of the experiments i did
yesterday was i had a little mystery box
and inside i stuffed it with 1 000
hard cash i put the keys to my range
rover
in the box and i offered people to buy
the box they didn't know what was in it
for as little as three pounds
i was like three pounds no one wanted to
take the gamble now that i understand
maybe they thought there's nothing in it
okay you could call them ignorant maybe
or you could say well they don't want to
take
the small risk but when i'm offering
people a house
i'm telling them what it is i'm giving
them the contract
i'm letting them read it no one took the
deal so it
makes me kind of think when i'm training
people you know
some people won't even be successful if
you write a contract
and you say have my house have it
they won't sign the paperwork it just
shows that some people will never be
successful now the interesting thing is
there's one lady
um and she was called georgia and i was
speaking to georgia in the park in hyde
park
and she was that close to signing the
contract she's there with the contracts
and she was like reading there
ah she said i think i'm gonna do this
this is and she was that close
but her friend next door was saying
don't do it
don't do it it's probably a scam be
careful
and her friend talked her out of it and
she was like you know what
i think i'll leave it and her and
georgia commented
on on the youtube video when she saw who
i was when she saw that it was legit
and she said i want to cry
is the office still there because i'll
take it
i mean i've spoke to georgia since i
didn't know at the time she was a
complete stranger i've spoke to her
since and she's a really
really good lady i think she's gonna i
actually think she's gonna be successful
in life i think she's smart i just think
that she had her friend with her who was
putting her off and her friend
seemed like a really nice person too you
know i'm nice people
i'm not i didn't do the experiment to
try and show how stupid people were
i didn't think and and i understand
you know with someone it sounds stupid
to be true and we're trained all our
life
if something sounds too good to be true
it probably is in fact she even said
this out she goes
if something sounds too good to be true
it probably is but in the world of
business
sometimes good thing and it's not like
the mystery box i understand it's not
like she didn't have time to read the
contract it's not like
she didn't know what she was doing i
wasn't asking her to do anything blind
i say read the contract read it
and i get that the contract might be
complicated for someone to read
on a good friday in a sunny park you
know
just with his contract but
that was a house man 450 pounds a month
every single month coming into your bank
that'll be enough to pay for your
holidays for the rest of your life
you know just because you're like i say
i can't be bothered it sounds a bit
dodgy interesting
so um georgia if you're watching this
yeah i think i do think you're amazing
i've spoke to you already and i i george
has actually agreed whether she'll do it
when i'm not sure but she agreed to have
an interview
with me on this channel and talk about
what happened and what was going through
her head
i'd be very up for doing that okay what
were the other comments
um i am the guy with the blue jacket
okay how is it that all these people at
the park
are somehow watching the video it's
crazy
i am the guy with the blue jacket i was
gonna buy it if you gave me five more
seconds or offer me some discount like
you did to others
again it's so easy to be like i would
have done it if i've had more time
i wouldn't if you'd have given it a bit
cheaper like you did some of the others
um but i think how you do anything is
how you do everything
anyone that's commenting on the channel
saying i'm good i missed out
i mean to be fair at least respect for
even
being being humble enough to watch the
video or
even having the decency to have a
conversation with me
these people are commenting they're not
the losers these are the people that are
like oh man i learned the lesson
okay either take the loss or take the
lesson but many people
wouldn't even listen to me i was like
free house and they were just like that
one lady i showed her the thousand
pounds i'm like look thousand pounds and
keeps your raindrop and you know she's
dead
haha you're funny what more evidence do
you need
what more evidence do you need she just
thought it was fake
it wasn't fake okay it makes me think i
should be stopping and talking to anyone
who wants to chat to me with a clipboard
you never know when we are so programmed
that if someone's trying to sell to us
it's like oh i don't want to solve it
interesting
um tom and ben
serious man says get liking people i
need part two in my life
if the video i said if the video hits a
thousand
likes i'm gonna do the same thing again
in a different location at the moment i
think it's on about 500 likes to shy 500
so if it gets to a thousand i will go do
the same thing again so go watch the
video and like it
sam hawkins would be interested to see
if you didn't cover up the mystery box
and see what they chose a depreciating
car or an appreciating house
that's the interesting point because the
car that i was giving away
for three pounds but they've been known
as a car was actually is actually worth
more than the house i would personally
take the car
over the house but then i would
immediately sell the car and buy two
houses with it and then you're left with
two
appreciating assets rather than one
depreciating asset
um kieran wright why were you rude to
the person that wanted to buy at the six
minute mark okay that was actually not
someone wanting to buy and it looked
like that
what happened was i was speaking to a
group of people
and i asked them if they wanted to go
ahead and they said no no thank you
i then walked away and it was actually
my videographer
that was like looking at me like what
happened and i said nope meaning
nope they didn't buy but it looked in
the video
like i was so i was approached by a
stranger and i just said nope
like i didn't want to talk to him in
fact it was me just talking to my video
i hope that clears that one up all right
um 2021 winner says this is a very
interesting video it seems
here that most people do not believe in
the law of receiving
and have limited faith great experiment
it's true most people aren't good at
receiving
i mean even when someone gives you a
gift sometimes it's a bit awkward to
receive you're like
well if someone compliments you you look
great today rather than just going thank
you
you know thank you it's like oh you're
good too you're deflecting the
compliment because you don't want to
receive
you know you'll apply for a job but in
your mind you're thinking i'm only going
to apply for a job between 25
and 30 grand a year because that's all
i'm worth because i'm not ready
to receive a 50 000 pounds per year job
i'm not ready to receive a free house
people can't aren't ready to receive um
you're right absolutely
adam says so this is what samuel gets up
to when he's bored
i i am curious by nature i'm curious to
see how people react
how people respond to opportunities um
so yeah it is the kind of thing that i
do for fun
improvement guy says this is genuinely
disheartening to witness the number of
people who don't even have
curiosity and justin i just said that
the reason i did it is because i'm
curious
but you're right people that weren't
receiving they were like i don't care
what's in the mystery box
i don't want to pay three pounds for the
mystery box i mean
i was standing there well-dressed
with a video production team
right they could see
i was there with the box with my like i
i agree with you i'd be like i'd be
thinking for three pound or five pound
or even ten pound
let's see what happens you know if this
dude's about to scam me on camera like
all right fine i i would have been
curious too
um and i'm curious to see other people's
lack of curiosity as well
kenny pittman so good just proves that
majority of people hate being sold to
and think everything has a cat
that is so true we do think everything
has a catch
i'm trying to give away a free house
and everyone's just like whatever joker
why because they've never probably seen
that before so they just think i've
never seen it before it can't be true
but if that's how we live our lives then
anything that
is like let me give you an example when
i first met my wife amanda
amanda's amazing i just come out of a
relationship where the
previous my previous girlfriend was a
little bit um
annoying yeah i had some personality
issues
in my opinion and i met my wife amanda
and i'm thinking wow like what's the
catch
what's the catch she seems too good to
be true and even in relationships
sometimes people will bring their past
baggage into new relationships or
they'll say
you know they'll try and find a problem
but here's the thing you'll find what
you look for
you'll sabotage every relationship you
have matthew
midland says they did not like your vibe
what the i find it hard to comprehend
how they also ignorance it's so
interesting because it's really easy
when you're
watching it and you're at home she'd be
like they're idiots
but then i mean every every single
person in the park
was like now i'm not interested every
single person online
watching it back is like there it is
pretty much every person in in the park
that said
no and then when i revealed who i was
were like i was just about to everyone
was like i'm just about to
even in the comments it was on the go on
the blue jacket i was about to
give me another five seconds so
hindsight is a wonderful thing it's kind
of the same in business when you miss an
opportunity and then you're like ah you
know someone
sometimes we've been negotiating with a
with their with the seller
we've put forward an offer and the offer
has not accepted to go come up with a
tiny bit higher
and i'm like debating with my wife
you've got a bit higher what do you
think
and then someone comes in and beats us
to it and then it's all oh we're just
about to it's kind of like human nature
but
um hindsight is a wonderful thing okay
next when was this recording this was
recorded
the day after it was it was put out on
air it was recorded on the good friday
it was posted out on the saturday and
today is the sunday that's the thing on
my youtube channel
i do a video every single day and
normally speaking when i put a video out
it's
just been filmed okay um last last last
question or comment is from
jada lenny sena why don't you do
something for your subscribers instead
i would be more than happy to grab it
now okay so question is
i am going to do a part two if the video
gets to go 1000 likes
so if you haven't watched it yet go
watch it if you've watched it already
watch it again
hit the like button when it gets to a
thousand i'm gonna do a part two
and second is what do you want me to do
for my subscribers let me know i'm
always happy to do giveaways or
any ideas let me know in the description
and i'll be sure to take you on board
thanks so much for watching and look
forward to seeing you next time peace